and now on to the next big segment oh
here we go
should should women be drafted should
they are you asking me yes I am asking
you I mean I don't think anyone should
be drafted but I mean get if there's
gonna be a draft I mean I I would fight
if it was a good good enough reason
Wells pulled in but we can we can talk
about the draft in general first yeah I
guess my mind goes let me give it buddy
the news real quick
yeah Rahm Politico women should be
eligible for the draft for the draft
Commission recommends the 11-member
commission's report commissioners report
was briefed to the Pentagon on Monday
and will be presented to the White House
and congressional staffers Tuesday oh my
gosh they say quote this is from today
yes today this is a necessary and fair
step making it possible to draw on the
talent of a Union unified nation in the
time of national emergency the
commissioners wrote in the 255 page
report obtained by Politico the report
does not require action but but its
recommendations paved the way for
lawmakers to move to include women in
the draft more than 100 years after
Congress passed the military Selective
Service Act in 1917 while no one has
been conscripted into the US military in
more than 40 years the Act requires all
American men to register for the draft
when they turn 18 men who failed to
register can be fined imprisoned and
denied services such as federal student
loans but again spokesperson did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment so they say this comes five
years after defense secretary ash Carter
formally rescinded the Pentagon's combat
exclusion policy that had prevented
women from serving in combat roles today
more than 200 24,000 women serve on
active duty and at least 30 women
completed the US Army Ranger school as
of August 2019 to the report my first
question is did they change the rules to
make it easier for them to pass in the
Marines right they do know that so we're
lowering our standard to put more people
in combat yeah I don't agree with that
me neither if they're gonna be a marine
my brother's a marine if you're gonna be
a marine you got to go through the the
training and you got to prove that
that's the best the best yeah man I'll
tell you what I've been in situations
with untrained people
and I feel bad for some of these Marines
that like they have to be put with
someone that didn't go through the
training that they did I want to know
what do you mean when I when I'm in it
so I've reported in a few you know major
urban conflict areas like I was in Egypt
during the revolution okay and I want to
know that the people who are with me
know how to take care of themselves it's
not about me being more prepared than
you you be more prepared than me it's
about both of us understanding what's
going on because I've been I was I've
been sent to places in conflict where
the people with me had no idea how to
respond to active gunfire or anything
like that and then I have to stick my
neck out and carry them it's like dude
if a fire breaks out can you get out of
the building can you escape do the
capabilities because I'll tell you what
imagine you you you can walk and run
like a regular person
yeah let's say they're sending you into
a mission a burning building
okay and the people with you also can
rock and run like regular people if they
put you in with somebody was in a
wheelchair
you'd be like listen man I got no beef
against you for being in the wheelchair
but now I literally have to pick you up
and carry you and it risks both of our
lives we have standards for a reason if
you're gonna go into a burning building
you got to be able to walk and run up
and down stairs like normal right make
sense oh yeah I'm not trying to be mean
anybody so so when I see stories like
this and so I don't have it pulled up
you're saying that they lower the
standards for women so then what I'm
gonna be in a conflict with you know
guns a-blazing and I'm gonna be like
great now I got to literally pick this
person up and run I don't know how many
women get into the frontlines of the
Marines probably not a lot yeah so if
anything I mean they say 30 women
completed the US Army Rangers Rangers is
pretty tough too that's extremely tough
well the question then is do they lower
the standards because I'm Russian I know
people who have served
I actually briefly lived on a military
base because my my sister you know she's
married to somebody was in the army yeah
my dad was Amer my dad's a former Marine
my brothers in the army and I've met a
lot of people and I hear a lot of the
same stories that the women who join
have like although the standards might
be there on paper they're not
practically applied yeah
what send and does it end with the army
like is this is this a thing everywhere
so I I was curious about the those army
guard women
the first article that comes up is the
inside story of how the army reduced
standards to get women through Ranger
training so well then oh and only third
and only 30 of them through with an
easier time to get through Los Angeles
wants more female firefighters but only
three percent of the apartment is female
you know a man so the official response
from feminists on all of this is that we
oppose the draft for men and women right
it's like okay then will you actively
protest the draft when they're not
pointing at you
Yeah right like so we're we're all
eligible for the draft you're nowhere to
be seen the moment the Commission steps
up and says we want to draft women they
all start screaming but we oppose the
draft for everybody no no you don't know
you don't you're only you're only
complaining now
dude I mean there there hasn't been a
draft in 40 years they said no there
hasn't really been like guys protesting
the draft at the same time so you know
it's kind of it's kind of you know say
that I do feel like women shouldn't be
drafted right no I mean that that would
be that would be giving everyone ammo to
be like well then you're just being
sexist and not a feminist right so here
would be the more traditionalist view
only men should be in combat the liberal
view would be I don't care who's in
combat so long as they can pass the test
boom the modernist view is agree with if
women can't pass the test the test is
sexist and needs to be made easier so we
get 50% women and 50% men I think with
all things you need to earn your keep
and earn your way in whatever it is if
it's a CEO I don't care if it's a guy or
a girl if they if they proved that they
know how to run a business that they
become the CEO dope it doesn't matter to
me who and what what gender you got
makes no difference as long as you have
the abilities that the jobs require you
know especially with the army check it
out the article says today the public's
opinion on including women in the draft
is myst mixed with 53% supporting the
change and 38% opposing it in a 2017
survey cited by the Commission the
Commission heard from many people who
fervently believed women should not be
required to register for the draft some
expressed can
CERN's that including women would damage
their ability to perform their unique
status in society as wives mothers and
caregivers others raised concerns over
the possible risks to women posed by
combat roles saying women are more
likely be injured in training that's all
true I personally don't care
women should be drafted they draft
doesn't just mean combat right exactly
we can draft you and say start making
widgets yeah you know I mean like we're
going to factory yeah our doctors and
nurses chefs whatever there's a bunch of
things you can do besides fighting or
you know being a firefighter or
something the bigger issue is inclusion
in combat so I look I'm not gonna speak
for the people who actually have served
they might know better than I would but
if it were me and I had to you know I'll
put it this way if you had to I'm gonna
play a game of pickup a pickup game
basketball with your buddies sure like
and you you were gonna be on a team with
a bunch of women versus a team of much
of guys like I think we can make an
really easy bet as to which team is
gonna win they're not trying to be mean
it's just reality the guys are more
likely be taller more fast which muscle
just a fact
now put life and death on the line man
if I depict I want a bunch of like six
foot five super ripped trained focused
fearless dudes and and women like that
exist too but it's the highest end of
the bell curve yes you know I mean so
there's that you're gonna find
substantially more men so here's here's
my ultimate thing women should be
drafted if men can actually nobody
should be drafted to be honest yeah but
in the current system I actually think
there is a real reason for the draft
here's my opinion on this if right now
they said we're gonna go over to the
Middle East and you're a-comin I'd be
like no I'm not you can't make me do it
you know sorry however if a bunch of you
know Chinese boats crashed into the
beaches of California I'd be alike let
me know what you need from me yes if you
think I'm saying if you come and invade
my home I'll be standing side by side
all my American brothers and sisters
saying tell me where to point damn
straight but I'm not gonna get in a boat
and go to the Middle East for oil no you
know or some some exactly right war
machine right now I don't agree with but
if if it comes to protecting my country
you then you know what all right yeah
your family your home here we go they
say experts argue that allowing women to
participate in the draft will enable the
military to access
well the will the will enable the
military access to a wider talent pool
as well as allow women to share in a
fundamental civil obligation it's a good
thing that you're gonna be forced to
join the army Hey sure it's insulting to
suggest America's mothers and wives and
daughters couldn't contribute whether
the need were rebuilding levees after
natural disaster or repelling an
invasion from our shores
Corey Schack director of foreign and
defense policy studies at the American
Enterprise Institute told the Commission
America's daughters should be slotted
into service as their physical and
emotional suitability proves capable
just like America's sons you know what
you know what I gotta walk some stuff
back oh yeah yeah when I'm talking about
a bunch of like trained fearless dudes
I'm thinking of like an excursion you're
an incursion like you're you're going in
somewhere really dangerous you're
surrounded by danger okay
no I if we're defending our shores from
incoming threat I don't care who you are
I take a gun point in that direction
yeah you know it's like that's that's
that's the American Way man bunch of
farmers picked a bunch of guns and told
the regulars the gtfo true so you know I
know back then they probably said keep
the woman safe and I think there's a
really obvious reason for it
evolutionary biology and psychology we
should totally get an evolutionary
psychologist in so there was there was
this idea karana virus no guess yeah
this is an idea I had yeah and I would
love to actually have one of these
evolutionary biologists or psychologists
chime in and correct me if I'm wrong
yeah definitely but you I think about it
I was playing Fallout I think it's in
Fallout 3 there's vault 68 and vault 69
okay I know those vaults are no no
remember I was give a quick bit of
context I wasn't familiar with the
Fallout game series its nuclear
annihilation wipes out civilization and
they're a bunch of vaults built by a
company called vault Tec it turns out
many of them are actually experiments
but everyone hides in these shelters
when the nukes go off vault 68 and vault
69 were vaults where there was nine like
99 men and one woman or 99 women and one
men one man and so you know I was
thinking about what would really happen
in a circumstance like that and one
thing is true if you have a civilization
they give a society or like a tribe and
there's a hundred men
hundred women and 99 women died you're
likely gonna collapse yeah because you
can have what one kid in nine months
it's over that we're a little over a
factor yeah that's true however if you
if 99 men die that one guy can have make
it happy 90th feet you know babies in
nine months and totally start
repopulating civilization and those
women who don't have kids are capable of
helping sustain and support and grow so
men are expendable yeah and so what ends
up happening is you we developed gender
norms like the draft based around the
fact that the women must survive
otherwise your civilization is over and
yet like the Vikings would steal the
women from like the British Isles or
whatever yeah that's the importance of
women to a functioning civilization
however today everything's safe we're in
a bubble yeah got too many people
already in the world though we are
seeing population decline which is kind
of scary but now because there's no real
fear of humans going extinct feminism
put them in combat get my gun whatever
we don't care we got more than enough
people across the board we're safe they
wanted equality well now they get it but
I don't know we'll see what happens this
this thing pops up every few years and
they want women to you know join and I
think the best point is that they can do
any other job it's interesting that
they'd be talking about this now with
all this pressure between US and China
you know because I mean we kind of toy
to edit a little bit every so often with
like Trump's been kind of warning us all
that like China's trying to take our
power away I'm sorry they we're actively
doing we're giving them our power yeah
as they're trying to take it it's like
you know they're taking we're giving and
now now they're in a really stressful
situation where they're losing their
grip on the world or Trump's like we're
gonna take our power back sorry
we're bringing it all back so now
they're kind of like stressed and now
they're talking about the draft yep
hmm and why women should be involved
yeah it's like yeah it's almost like
they're getting ready for something
whenever there's a big crisis I assure
you people in these rooms aren't saying
like do we have enough people yeah and I
don't think they do
right I mean I don't know what the
status of our
areas compared to China they have won
what 1.3 billion people 330 million so I
got a billion more people they have a
massive standing army but they don't the
same tech we do yeah we have like a
ridiculous amount of military tech bases
all over the world true
so we're tough and we also have you know
we also have coalition you know with
like European countries and and to
whatever extent Canada is part of our
coalition I don't know what you know
right now I think there's a lot more
people who are more interested in global
stability but China wants to be a bigger
power and they've been pushing and
stealing and stripping things away and
are crony politicians have been boning
up whatever they've asked for eking
their money well now that the world is
kind of falling apart I don't even think
it's necessarily China right it's it's
like we're in a chaotic situation as it
is yeah like theoretically we're facing
a serious threat and if it got really
bad to the point where we saw like
twenty or thirty percent mortality we'd
all probably be conscripted to some
degree true or actually I'd be willing
to bet I'd get a National Security
Letter saying like these are your
propaganda talking points I'd be totally
willing to bet that'd be the case that's
a good point
yep like you need to spread this
information up you need to tell people
to do this like if we were facing like a
serious threat they would probably go to
people like me and like Joe Rogan and be
like if you say this will shut you down
here's what we want you to say yeah
because information is we all turn you
off yep or I'm gonna lock you up and if
they're even worse yeah true but what
I'd imagine everybody would be
contracted in some capacity if the
mortality rate was really really really
high mm-hmm
yeah man people don't realize that we
live on man we are in a beautiful
paradise Golden Age they really don't
realize that societies like give thanks
every day for what you've got please
we are lucky here's what I think about
the second America I don't think the
Second Amendment was necessarily about
stopping a tyrannical government okay
a lot of people say that you know if the
US government goes out of control then
it's the right of the people to fight
back and that is true that is things
that was said by the founding fathers I
think the Second Amendment Second
Amendment Second Amendment was simple
somebody might try and invade our
country if everybody has guns make
and that's surely been true yeah
what's the feint what's the famous quote
is there's a gun behind light of glass
yes there is a gun behind every blade of
grass in the United States and that
makes it impossible for foreign armies
to actually invade
yeah it's true you can't occupy a street
corner with you know with a missile with
it with a fighter plane and so if
everybody those countries gets trapped
you can come in there to be firing back
at you so they can't do anything mm-hmm
that's what it's all about so we
actually as part of the foundation of
this country know that we were facing
serious threats throughout our entire
existence Chinese citizens have guns
I'm just curious I don't actually know
Tibet like my life that they can't but
I'm not sure so so I I went to Texas
several months ago when I was on Glenn
this is last year I was on Glenn Beck's
podcast okay and his studio is awesome
he's got a bunch of newspapers from like
the 1800s and one of them I was reading
a story about a guy who was staying us
out of a bar smoking and another guy
just pointed a like a pistol in his
chest and pulled the trigger
Bam's jeez yep life was nuts back then
people died all of the time Red Dead
Redemption - people are killing
everything all the time it's like this
is my home and yeah could you imagine
like actually living in a world where
you were scared that a bear might attack
your town
no and you were had to had weapons or
the random guy passing by you might
shoot you and take your stuff yep
without a thought and that still might
happen today but we've moved like it's
just well I mean it there's probably
more numerous because there's more
people but it's crazy to me to think
back like 200 years ago you could be
walking down the you know walking down a
dirt path and someone could be like I'm
gonna take your stuff blam your stuff
and no one would ever figure out who did
it exactly you you you you show up at
night you wear a mask you you take
someone down you take it it's over
people don't realize we've built this
society that is so safe this comfortable
bubble we live in you know feminism only
exists because of the security and
safety we have if we if we go to war
it's gonna be it's like well it's like
that article we were reading the other
day where the woman said were going back
to the 1950s yeah you betcha
yep yeah
article going on like a meme I think
it's just like there's silence from all
the different talking points that all
these screamers on Twitter and all the
different places that those like we
haven't heard anything about any of
these issues
no not like what issues just
oh right social justice a little bit
there's there's been one there was a
story that said like trans affirming
surgeries it arts like the corona virus
epidemic shows how society views trans
affirming surgeries as like cosmetic and
you know or something like that and it
was like from the perspective that these
people's lives will be saved by these
surgeries it's like I mean yes but they
can wait can it wait well they are you
know they say people are dying they're
killing themselves and it's like right
but that person is choking on their own
choosing two items on their own fluids
and their name is scratching and clawing
at the wall desperate for help right now
right yep and there were other articles
going around about how like Nazis are
trying to weaponize the corona virus and
it's like dude but for the most part
it's it's out yeah you know nobody it's
it's it's luxury it's luxury politics
they only exist in wealthy advanced safe
civilizations in societies that's true
and once conflict and crisis comes
everyone's got to do their part you know
that that's conscription man it's like
listen I don't I don't agree with the
draft I don't to an extent like being
sent overseas like the Vietnam thing was
insane yeah exactly
well what would happen right now for
aliens invaded you better believe every
human being would take up arms through
that I would join the cult the you know
the global coalition right Earth front
to fight back against the alien threat
definitely you'd have no choice right or
we're gonna lose like we didn't we just
watched War of the Worlds right yeah
like Tom Cruise didn't want to fight
he's like the main character he's like
running to save his family and then he
ends up fighting and you know he well
technically he was only running to fight
to grab his screaming daughter over and
over and over right I feel like that's
really what the movie was
so you're saying is CGI in the event of
a major catastrophe we just have to wait
for Earth to
to kill the the aliens yep yep that's
basically what happened in the movie I
just spoiled it for all of you too bad
too bad it's all that's wailed yeah
that's good that actually alright well
good for being that old thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you